the london ambulance service has  confirmed um that a child has been  killed at  in the explosion that house explosion  that took place at thornton heath so  london ambulance service confirming that  in that explosion that took place at  thornton heath a child has been killed  um  there was the latest was that three  people had been seriously hurt it's been  put down to a gas explosion as you can  see from that footage an entire house  was destroyed in um in that thornton  heath it's in south london  four people were treated at the scene of  the blast three were taken to hospital  with injuries believed to be  life-threatening and we've heard now  from  the london ambulance service that it's  been confirmed that a child has been  killed in that explosion at thornton  heath